joseph's in kansas city hi joseph what's
up
good afternoon gentlemen yes sir honor
to be talking with uh with you and uh
ken on the show today
um this is more of a mindset question
more than do we have the funds
okay um i have actually been unemployed
for 10 months my wife has been working
i do collect i do collect
uh basically we've saved money aside to
build a home
and uh it we're having a we've been
saving for over 20 years to actually buy
or build
a newer home and now it's come time
i've been i inherited property three
years ago
and it was actually burned down b's
property but
beautiful piece of land and you know we
currently own the whole our home now
we have absolutely no debt we have an
old dave ramsey way
uh you know our newest car is from 1999
that we keep it running
[Music]
so you know we're looking for for
actually some guidance beyond family
because everyone else in the family says
live on debt we do not believe in that
at all we have absolutely no debt
so regarding this it's more of a mindset
question
we we've been saving for 20 years we can
actually we have the cash to build the
home
but we're just having such a hard time
of actually finding that contract to go
ahead and begin to build
why because it's been over 20 years
of saving living very frugal way below
our means
which would make me want to sign that
contract and get this crap done
that's a good point dave and yeah you
know
both of us we've never made more than 20
bucks an hour
uh the house bill itself is going to be
about 240
000 how much does it say uh we currently
have
416 000 cash in retirement we have 308
000.
okay so um what is it that's scaring you
it's the fact of
i just have not ever made a whole lot of
income and it's going to take a long
time to replace
that 230 240 000 that we're going to be
spending
so primarily it's a matter of finding
another position
i'm actually starting my own investment
advisory firm i've been financial
coaching no fee for years
and it's something that i love to do but
i'm still looking for employment
and uh well if you want to wait until
you get employment and that gives you
the sense of stability to do this that
would not be illogical yeah
but joseph here's the deal you got
plenty of money but if
if if that's the last emotional hurdle
hurdle
uh that says you know i really want to
have a job for a break ground on this
thing
there's nothing that says you have to
start today
right and uh dave i gotta address this
joseph when dave asked you point blank
what the fear is it's
it's i've saved so much money over so
long a period of time and once i spend
it on this house
it's gone and it's not let's say that 10
15 years from now you want to sell that
house that's going to appreciate you
paid cash for it if i'm understanding
that right that money's coming back and
then some
yeah and the home you're involved that
is perfect yeah yeah and the home you're
in is paid for and it turns into a
really nice rental property i suppose
hi yes sir it's actually it's just a
little too better in the home
uh you know joseph rental property do it
you're ready to go if you want to wait
till you get a job that's fine
but you're ready to go there's nothing
financially out of place here it's just
hard
you're right it's hard to turn loose so
it took you a long time to get here
and you kind of like that pile of money
being there yeah and uh
that's a normal human reaction so but
it's
you did it you you this was what you did
it for now enjoy the fruits of your hard
work and discipline